Hausa go rest my name is Greta welcome
back to amnesia a machine for pigs
today you might notice already the video
is [ __ ] long as hell isn't a yellow
[ __ ] so we're gonna have a good time
tonight we're gonna chill out if you
have one hour I don't know how long I
guess in one hour whenever I have to
spend when may I fill on it aren't you
sweet
the reason why I waited with the series
was because I just think people were
more into outlast
and I wanted to have one series at a
time I think two is to his way to my
what the hell you doing aren't you
excited [ __ ] doors every [ __ ] door
really I thought it was kind of funny
also a lot of people thought they made a
PewDiePie reference because a barrel
kept rolling down the hallway I'm pretty
sure they didn't put imputed by referees
in this parade in fact what is this
pulley town thank you Jesus whoa it
plays music alright well let's follow
the golden pipe now okay let's not
followed the golden pipe what if we put
a little Sumatra Samata in there yep
nailed it
why was that do exactly outside our [ __ ]
again go and gah ah [ __ ] actually let's
bring one in case we need one you never
know it kind of sucks
what the hell stop blink gank you piece
of [ __ ] eBay Atlantan it kind of sucks
that you can't [ __ ] pick up jigsaw I
guess this thing I can catch don't laugh
at me battery box whatever you are big
[ __ ] stupid
woah it's teddy
oh yeah I'm pretty good daddy it's been
a while yeah whoa [ __ ] babies come
back yet I'm a [ __ ] Kelly that
doesn't even make any sense
all right listen ah I just don't feel
like reading it I'm sorry I just don't
you can pause and read notes if you want
to okay so we're back here and they're
the same broke so we can go [ __ ] cool
if we really wanted to we could have
just crawl outside and jump back in that
that's something you could have done in
outlast nothing listen I'm just kidding
can you sense a bit of sarcasm I think I
can not because I don't even know what
that is okay oh my friend you made it so
happy you made it
alright moving on yes of course it's
pretty it fell onto his hands and they
eroded in front of you
uh-huh just dumps just dumps [ __ ] those
thumbs next time we will use an equal
mix of infusion vitae and all go and
dispersor no no just take him out you
could dump him in the river for all okay
now you just be me
Tara don't deserve it the level of
design is really beautiful it looks very
nice very appealing this game most of
the time except that [ __ ] barrel hey
hey let's strap a box on the barrel whoa
and they [ __ ] out these things oh my god
oh my god oh my day that okay fine I'll
read the notes a warning in flame will
it is burning it as bleeding from each
hole yeah fore-and-aft leaking down my
legs blood experiment my lungs are in my
vomit I pass thoughts of my organs now
into the filthy stone drink this he says
and I did drink it I did do that because
of the changes is a ripple in Urmi my
teeth sneeze out and scatter like mice
in the dark I cannot find them all
gathering what I can push them back in
my gray gums with my fingers but the
nails are
we've been falling out drank it he says
it'll be the running of the fever
because not us all can take the change
on the other table at least I can't be
not [ __ ] stupid I beast under a
blanket I never wanted to see under that
but he drank it too he passed it under
the blanket and I heard it drink
yeah God Almighty how can a man shed
some it's still okay I'm glad I read
that all right well let's put you in
there sir
oh my deck has been sent away let's see
what it does okay excellent
what did I do
pigs it'd be kind of spooks if you saw
something in there but I doubt they
would
oh this is kind of cooking well [ __ ]
pigs what the [ __ ] what the hell am I
supposed to do you get you start chasing
me you catch it
alright block the door block the door
you can't just start chasing me without
me B that's not cool
see he's not even there are you oh he
locked the door for me wow what a
gentleman I know he was a gentleman des
see now the OMD has been oh [ __ ] that
was a where did I throw it
[ __ ] well I throw it
we need the OMD and they OCP and the PPP
there you are friend excelencia
I mean excelsior you know what shut up
[ __ ] stupid ad Gio I'm gonna bring you
for good luck Ronald that is your name
ow sorry about that Rona don't worry
about it parents like I'm a on spinning
ow
don't let her bad pace I'm your new best
friend but you're gonna have a mighty
great time together
aside Serrano yes that subheads just cut
me holy shut health so you have to save
me sorry Donald ok now we can click hey
wow I thought it was one door closes and
the other one opens but I guess whoa
I'm sparing cats that's ok I can see
that that's fit well that was fun wasn't
it yes pets whoa can I drink this
what is this is exactly
so I filled you up cool and all the
doors closed I guess we can just go hey
can we now I swear to God there was a
door here what say don't go away Rana
sorry pets I'm just I fell so okay what
do we do with this I know we throw it on
the lock yes Oh what do I do now Ron oh
I'm sorry I killed you
I didn't get to say goodbye he didn't
even just try out the birth machine god
damn it
this gave me something to throw yes
alright ha dokkan dokkan what else do
you want from me
I'm quite serious right now what the
[ __ ] do you want from me do you want to
give birth is that that you want to give
birth hey go ahead man go ahead now
parents place I'm not pregnant
Oh how do you know you dirty [ __ ] let's
be honest here what is this oh it's a
lamb oh maybe I'm supposed to direct the
lamp on the thing and it will like heat
it up and [ __ ] okay cool
high five lamb you're my new best friend
let me make out I need to suntan a
little bit Sorry Sorry Sorry
hey extra points for nudity come on
let's be at whoa okay
ah
[Music]
[Music]
hey I'm tired it's an afternoon well
somebody's in the [ __ ] hurry I hate
my kids her [ __ ] [ __ ] someone
didn't smack them enough
alright fast ow faster they say well we
progress I'm proud of me I'm proud of
you I'm proud of poo my poo come on
let's round it
have you never not being proud of your
poo yeah I didn't think so
maybe never just nah I'm not gonna go
there actually but hey maybe one day oh
this is nice
I wanted to go in holiday this is
perfect I'm so happy oh look at that
oh ho artefacts Wow this is my best day
ever
we can use the flow to drive the turbo
I like a note thank God excreta flooding
through these tow yeah we can use this
to set the steel reduction and ensure
constant so that's [ __ ] whoa
livin [ __ ] nice they just couldn't come
up with something themselves so they
just split the water monster there
that's
I'm okay with that I miss them what shut
up you may be a peg but dad does not
make me scared of you my house n noise
coming from whoa hi sexy
work it work it work it but he can't
work that girl can't work
that's so cute he can walk on two legs
that's adorable
that's a kill shot
oh no one video if I find a snack I will
come back here and I will give it to you
yes yes yes there will be some nice I'm
so happy in this place look at I oh I
can pull you nice name that puzzle oh my
god I'm a genius
yes text is that right pot o phone okay
I'll see you there
haha I kinda I can't it kind of sucks
that Manders doesn't seem to have much
of a personality because in in amnesia
II know what's his name Daniel is that
it
you know why that showering the water
will chill we cool
we're not cool we're not cool it's okay
it's okay I get it you have brunch it's
from the last game he was insane or
whatever Daniel I don't think it's
Daniel I don't know he was insane it was
a [ __ ]
this is funny mandus seems this like
okay shitty [ __ ] are we going backwards
shut up
alright we need to drain the other one
where's the other one I don't think I
know what I'm doing it here whoa
is there someone standing in the doorway
or did it was that just an illusion I
kind of feel like I saw something that's
kind of creepy if they did it I'm not
sure oh yeah yeah yeah this is our party
right no yeah yeah this is our party
this is this is where the party started
cool cool cool it's so [ __ ] cool what
if we go over here yeah this looks cray
well this looks like a maze
jeez shut up
whoa what are you a little grabby [ __ ]
save them we can set them free we can
replace a rotten old world with a clean
new one and your engineer this visionary
with really fast upon this course does
he share your views indeed he does
indeed he does the poor fellow has seen
it all before
now this is not the first great
civilization he has wept for and so you
said about things that music therefore
no actually actually these things cannot
be left to rot upon the tree and
sponsors were remarkably easy to find
I tell you professor a trail of greed
brings rich men to your door like big
stir truffles
all right that's good to know I never
had a truffle I thought it was chocolate
I thought it was the same I know I can't
believe it either but that's just how it
is
did I just walk in a circle come by a
guy do you think I believe I did yes of
course English men in pink
twerk it girl that undead lead howdy
twerk it that is some [ __ ] sexy [ __ ]
I'm sorry with the pictures looks funny
yeah like at the amnesia monster looks
funny too oh oh it's just about I do
believe so yes
the museum also looks at their first
amnesia sorry there's something here
right yeah good thing you can pause and
read I'm sorry I just don't care much
for notes in the first time you shot the
first nerd you click on it gives you
voice acting introduces you to the story
and after that you're kind of interested
but in this one I'm just like alright
while we drain the [ __ ] that's what we
did so now we can jump on [ __ ] stains
this is kind of like real life isn't it
alright let's do it what
if like the lantern is a cue for a bad
[ __ ] to happen instead of the music but
their first anisha had I think if the
first ameesha had like sometimes the
music would come when you're getting
chased and sometimes it just don't
interrupt me you little [ __ ] and then
sometime you just wouldn't so you would
think that you're being chased but then
all the sudden you were nobody you
understand what I'm saying I don't so
that's great for you why are we going
through this [ __ ] again
get it [ __ ] okay now I just feel
terrible that door needs to be closed
somehow there we go
they put so much time and effort to
build this thing so of course they have
to use it twice that's so cool that's
the cool thing not complaining
[Music]
okay I'm bad
what I have to turn it off is that it I
keep forgetting what the [ __ ] it is I
have to do here thank you thank you
jeez I gotta be home I stopped by you
know we don't have baby piggy Oh piggy
you done there I think pig is inspired
by Miley Cyrus oh look that's two of
them the music is awesome I gotta give
that to them ah you can't just hit piggy
look your heart is feeling I apologize
whoa do you see that [ __ ] jump all
right well let's party with the piggies
I'm pop yay I'm pop yay a pop yay uh-huh
open please thank you thank you thank
you what is this place exactly the game
kinda wants me to go in there beautiful
music
it's [ __ ] creepy and weird all right
hello piggies
I want to play with you whoa
all right now let whoa why is it shaking
why is it shaking I do believe I'm
inside a giant women plate pleasure okay
no which wha well I guess that one nah
[ __ ] going down the pipes bro which oh
okay a ladder but how do you walk down
the ladders I guess you can't
which one is doing that chicken thing
again J's out 360 ladder shot nailed it
[Music]
uh-huh a big I guess we're just going
down I like the idea that you keep going
down to something to discover the truth
and I don't know just going down
underground it's it's kind of creepy in
my opinion I like that idea
how you doing i holding up you scared I
don't think so
there's nothing scary so far the Pyxis
looks funny like I just want to have
them as a little pet I'd be happy to
have them as a man siren a woman's
sermon if you know what I mean edit that
out Fitz am I kidding
as we disembark even through my fever I
saw the detritus of this so-called
progress I sought starvation and disease
rot and destruction polluting the waters
of the Empire we are ruinous you and I
to all of us and we make the world ugly
and you took it upon yourself to act as
Redeemer professor I would not be so
presumptuous I am merely a conduit I am
constructing not gonna hear it from here
oh it's those [ __ ] kids again plot
twist that kids are dead whoa whoa okay
I wonder if we're gonna ever go in and
share it go to school
I dragged myself deep into the temple
towards a wind that helped the voices of
my children
[Music]
well it's there I saw something I can't
see it's so motion blurry I just saw
something you read there I don't know
about your breath but [ __ ] ladders out
see that's the thing why they should
have the ladder not an @ @ @ @ @ @ @ @ @
n cuz now I don't give a [ __ ] about my
health it will regenerate anyway oh [ __ ]
oh look what you've done you've made a
fool of everyone wait what was that a
jump scare really what happened I know
ok oh I love all that I'm being very
creative the episode but I have to like
it so I'm gonna keep doing it a lot of
people I've read a lot of like
discussions about this game and a lot of
people are saying that this game doesn't
have jump scares and the first time
Nisha had a lot of them but it just
couldn't be more wrong which I don't
understand at all but hey I do love the
level design in them and the sounds in
this game I think they did an amazing
job on that I kind of wish they would
both make the game together instead of
one of them making the game you know I
think they both have things to learn
from each other
frictional games in Chinese room that is
well I just pull the lever which did
something so yay yay for me
oh you weren't there before you little
[ __ ]
I hate him you want that before tea that
you know [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm Joe Blow 360
pictures that's right my name is nandus
and I'm here to man ducks
best joke I ever made thank you thank
you
ah well well we can't dull what but the
pigs crying now are they not fabulous
enough that's impossible
they could be top models all of them
they are [ __ ] beautiful I would date
one of them job no don't jump-scare say
said oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] pigs man don't
eat me I tastes like solid but you're a
vegetarian well [ __ ] me why did you eat
me into begin quick ha stupid idiots
ah no jump scares they said it will be
fun
ah [ __ ] ah that tastes like diarrhea
alright what are we doing here I can't
go there well I guess we just have to go
hey don't wait
genius Pierre strikes again genius boot
strikes again girl genius through France
again any more notes hasn't been an
owner while I wanted to read no oh [ __ ]
we came from err I'm an idiot
well [ __ ] wait what I come from there
now I'm just confused I'm just very
confused but okay
what in the heavens I keep thinking I'm
gonna run out of oil I swear to God
didn't I come from here what the hell
you can't do that let me out ham
oh it's that [ __ ] pig huh it's trying
to [ __ ] with my brain and see if I go
crazy
well you're not getting this Swedish
person you're [ __ ] but seriously
though how do I get out I'm crazy
let me out what the [ __ ] is this where I
am
oh it looks like we're almost almost
there in the party in the frickin party
girl are you [ __ ] with me you may
need a cogwheel there looks like yeah
there we go okay you try to be sneaking
[ __ ] no fifth place III study math I
know how these things work
oh you need to be in there yeah yep
right there that's what I was gonna put
it now we can put all the cogwheel girls
maybe needs another one well there is
one here luckily you might look more
like a like a yep anything else nope
spin the wheel they said and spill the
way like ow hey high five
nice nice
now the door magically opened how
wonderful all right next adventure wait
what did i do exactly what did i do
exactly you [ __ ] barrels Chara whoa
blood that can't be good
it finishes potatoes but spoiled little
brat Pig whoa mandus don't be scared
we're on a holiday remember hey you love
this splash of water madness
yes how there's a stone break that lamp
yes of course what about the pipe is
there a pipe or anything oh there's a
ladder okay it even dad if I my let me
kiss you mwah
you leave me in the [ __ ] pants I hate
you hahaha
silly way men they don't know what
they're talking about okay now where are
we
yes of course this way yeah
say so now what was the point of all
that
oh I can walk here and see that shut up
no one cares about you okay
well this looks interesting
am I supposed to just go here really
well that was easy okay
I have to do this [ __ ] again huh
there we go
let me go everyone happy everyone happy
yeah good potatoes nice and we'd bet it
we're done Billy do it give yourself a
round of applause
but those machines can look like angry
piggies angry piggies isn't that an
iPhone game hey old si sold out man
my butt hurts today I don't know what's
the matter
ya ever ever had but hard days that
actually made sense
holy [ __ ] alright new area huh I guess
this is the final area according to the
map at least I like change that's so
nice decoration I like on they decorate
you know they used only ugly pipes going
around in there anyway
okay stop no unauthorized oh okay well
stupid sides can't tell me what to do
and then kVAL to London and you set me
upon a mental peace and then you went
into the house and the servants
cool sorry there dad despite me being
very critically fun to playing like I'm
I'm not being critical all actually
alright we're going down cool funky town
what is that oh that's the machine well
that actually looks pretty badass not
gonna lie
okay whoo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's finish this [ __ ] God Christ what
is this place
see that's what I want more up man is
showing some [ __ ] personality I know
he forgot I didn't [ __ ] but damn and I
know in half life half life or whatever
Gordon Freeman
he doesn't be either but at least you
know about Gordon from how other people
interact with you but there's no
interaction so you literally know [ __ ]
about this character and throughout
except these [ __ ] balance is
completely humane that's good don't we
judge the acceptable level of suffering
by the human condition oh let me choke
navikev hey come on
come on what do you want for me what the
hell do I need to spend something what
is it what is it what's the problem talk
to me doctor pop a pill all right there
we go
where the pig is where the pig is where
the pig where the peg where the pigs at
papa Houma in the perc damn way back
there
all right what's the problem wow you
were close why are you hey you got your
welcome sale a silly silly you see that
bug that's printed balls on the [ __ ]
ladder isn't that I like that god dammit
I'm through short tall whatever
alright alright
he brought the [ __ ] are you doing here
why does it need to be a battle there
Wow all right chief chief [ __ ]
hey within it high five an Apple Apple
goat goat it was to go to the lawn the
goat hated the world you want to see
blood he wanted the pigs to burn the pig
to kiss childhood they bullied him for
having horns does
[ __ ] oh that's s
what's this
now that's [ __ ] up
all right that one is green that that da
bah [ __ ] levers everywhere why the
hell do I need to do now
alright open please
there better be a good good sorry binded
machine maybe I knew about it already
maybe they were making what why aren't
you opening I thought I thought that was
the point oh I had to pull a Z ice
[Music]
[Music]
you promised me my children best centers
ever more take more take whoa are they
my boys oh jeez you're ugly
[Music]
[Music]
it sounded like they were no I'm not
gonna say
[Laughter]
hi well they're still calling and
emerging I raised my head to an uncaring
Sun and I cursed this world of pain and
despair okay
this civilization built on the rickety
bones of the unfortunate on the green
and swell of Mammon and Empire
cradling a stone egg and kissed my
children
do I get to I left a little note that's
adorable
can a man construct himself a new can a
man on realizing who he is on what he
has become tear himself apart down to
the bricks and begin again our our soul
just tiny cog wheels and clockwork and
intricate a machines to serve a function
that upon reflection we might set to a
new task can Amanda be defined by his
action defined by what we've defined by
which defined by that which he now finds
um I bow here abhorrent such is
sabotaging this body his machine until
those children of the his soul turning
to new motion and he may awake to a new
Sun a new year and a new century with
hope in his heart as I reach my hand to
hit the exposed wires I ask myself this
it's Redemption possible for such create
such a creature as I and if not then
surely better to die among my creation
than continue to live as Marcel so they
made the machine to prevent something
bad
but instead they did more bad is that it
cool
children really are the most wonderful
useful creatures the unfortunates from
the orphan have proven this okay they
use children
wonderful
what is missing
something missing
I don't see it
we're here now
and that's how it's done well that was
easy
I like how both out lesson Anisha where
something about shutting down a machine
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay I can walk here I didn't see
that ow
daddy that's it good
I asked um cetirizine fire always burns
little mandus but it purifies and it
makes that you did it hurt to carve out
the fevered flesh did it hurt to cut
free the gangrenous foot ask instead
this can we save them when did I say
that that is not me
that is not me yes it is madness yes it
is but this is really annoying why don't
have to walk so slow look it's a letter
thing you kill your children - you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
so many of them so they wore these masks
well this is pretty [ __ ] creepy ah I
was actually about to say I was happy
that they didn't use this white light
like the didn't Anisha cuz that was
[ __ ] annoying how's this there's a
spoon of Medicine I says and it's a
silver spoon what you did get burning
burn holding ever so painful for mommy
dear but grab so hard it was in a little
screaming red fist
later you use your spoon to dig a hole
in Garland to get all the way to Mexico
and then you did it once with your spoon
on the way to stay fat this spoon was
the same you gave your twins but then
you used it to dig a hole to their
Clockwork Souls and you ate up their
hearts like soup on their way to keep
you fat fat little more where will you
dig next I asked you and your little
silver spoons made for the silver spine
of your children and left in their hair
of your dearly departed dear sweet Jesus
my darling the bread what
I become they're really dragging that
[ __ ] out aren't they all right let's
follow piggie piggie okay what are you
doing in my chill actually I don't care
what is this Oh No
no pressure they said what the [ __ ] is
that sound oh wow I can fit over them
but I have to do that I didn't see that
there was a glass there anyway
oh that's all okay I was supposed to put
lemon dude in sneaking hey beautiful I
wasn't mad we all can hug let's all hug
that's all huh let's all [ __ ] out if
I carry [ __ ] you're ugly are there I'll
get their gang banging it up now that's
adorable seriously sexy lay that oh you
can climb ladders fatty fat what are you
doing stop
stop it that's not Christian idiots the
[ __ ] do they come from anyway
oh well
alright within it I'm happy [ __ ]
that's the wrong turn I know I took the
wrong turn
alright that's this way of course okay
yeah yeah yeah big it oh whoa calm down
game it's oh thank god I wanted some
fighting done oh okay we go here
I'm so happy I will save them
piggies yeah yeah it's great this is a
letter all right what are we going out
there's a line it looks the same
whoa hello
it's time for Rihanna for her comeback
puh-puh-puh poker face pop-up poker face
well are they chasing barrels well see I
knew there were my friends
see I knew it I knew we were girl could
be friends ha ha ha you made it
that's impossible biggest I told you to
kill the battles done distr Donders
Starla semi-open here that's shut up
the fools God oh there unleash upon the
world how about we just [ __ ] shoot
them well what are you doing but net net
net net net dead dead dead net ice
they just have to throw a naked guy in
there didn't they the pig is they took
his clothes and left him to shame whoa
what are they going because the door
well I'll collect okay
no one misses a port ran up some organs
in the world would thank you for it
disappear a [ __ ] and a gentleman
applauds you call a beggar and a lady
walk safely again I hate them I hate
them more than any of the others this
privilege this pretension these
so-called leaders these pillars of
society these are rich and fanciful they
wear their filth on the inside but
they're no less dirty I have plans for
them all we will feed them and then we
will feed from them well that sounds
like a [ __ ] party that sounds like a
party I'm up for
all right chair oh my god it's just a
piss
you're finally gonna acknowledge me yes
it's time I gotta use you as a shield
from the really I'm sorry about I wanted
to come with you god dammit Chad asked
you for one favor and you let me what
the hell is that noise coming honey
Chad I need you you were supposed to be
my chill oh wait there's another one
what's that [ __ ] pant pant pant hi Anna
you can't just leave me you son of a bad
guy that's fine all right I'm gonna go
down there I can't that's [ __ ] stupid
all right
yeah we'll be proper she'll my friend
all right as I'm excited I'm pop I feel
pretty confident yeah
I'm a great I got great feeling
all right what about in here nope what
about in here yes but yeah
protection you gotta wear it what the
[ __ ] are you serious where did you go
time
oh okay hi couch what's up sorry I
didn't see you
that's alright alright well we're really
really really what the [ __ ]
what's your problem mate
I'm so sorry it's okay am i ruining the
tension I think yes here have a friend
but parents come on be nice okay
wasn't I supposed to be there hello
knock-knock I guess he wants his privacy
whoa what's that a jump-scare good
terrifying all right this way that's why
my friends Oh sexy lady I'm sorry I want
this to be scary but it really isn't
they're just cute
[Music]
don't think I don't see you barrel the
redemption for the wildly well that's
his fan-fucking-tastic
you [ __ ] mouth oh I can touch you can
i all right I'm gonna use you as a
shield you [ __ ]
yeah we'll ever wind heads what it's all
over we will kill ya we unleash the
biggest evil I'll bear the peg is Kate's
you too and you will see I'll show you
open this place
all right don't join pets you have no
idea what you can do
shut up I know exactly what I'm doing
I've gotta [ __ ] kill the barrels I
gotta [ __ ] kill it really really well
[ __ ] I tried hi
the piggies are so preoccupied in
running in every other direction that I
am NOT in it's ridiculous
all right there's some light there is
there something no this [ __ ] okay
well that's just [ __ ] great
Hey
ah [ __ ] hey how you doing
but you know like Oprah ow ow [ __ ]
hell man why would he touch my ass I
don't understand that's actual on
harassment I'll let you know
hi calm down whoa what it's [ __ ]
either way idiot oh that's lovely
alright now think I'll go here
what what just happened I think I was
supposed to die they feel bad for
madness though not [ __ ] they asked it as
well
back we go huh
so that's the party pooper but hey you
can't if you're wrong 99.99999% of the
times you're probably never right ever
actually the odds are really not in your
favor so that's how it works on they
took the pig they cut off the head and
they make nice swagalicious shirts out
of them well I always wondered where the
swag come from I mean it all makes sense
now
dirty peasants dirty swagalicious fun I
can't talk too much today I'm sorry I
should just stop talking what about this
lever
how are you lever I feel like you're so
underrated you had no pants what people
just jerk me all day that's a good thing
you piece of [ __ ] okay all right we're
in the center cool
whoa Sato see my friends
wonderful so they build the piggies out
of the dead bodies of people that's
[ __ ] awesome
like a mass production of them I mean
that could literally make the biggest
orgy in the universe think about it
not too hard yeah that's right that's
what I'm talking about girl all right
yeah whatever we do video now I wasn't
supposed to do that well [ __ ]
I told you brothers if you're wrong
night bow oh wow
that's improved oh that opened okay the
prison of the flesh free to ascend the
smoke to the stars and the good the word
how will we say that
mandus show me these food I do not see
them
okay pull the lever they said
ah see let's see hey let's do that again
that was fun oopsie oopsie man I mean to
throw that I like the idea of the
piggies or whatever that's pretty cool
this game is actually pretty [ __ ]
cool I just I just think it would be a
lot better if you didn't have amnesia in
the title I think if they if they just
released this game by themself okay like
people here know I'm richer than it's
carrying this it's it's kind of scary
but it's not nearly as scary so if they
really wanted to make it a good sequel
out of amnesia I don't think this is the
right approach but maybe that's just me
now we can go there is that it now we
can go to the piggies the finger was
like oh wait he [ __ ] up he touched my
mic [ __ ] okay Lea the electricity gone
sir wait did that reset itself
this pig is still there oh he got
electrified okay that's cool we don't
want to put that there then well thank
you no thank you bells well thank you
not today maybe another day it's time to
be gay huh what a rhyme hey it could be
a girl you know
beautiful beautiful lady that is very
nice I can't spend the wheel pills now
they nailed it okay
one more
maybe creepy we came back alive but I
thought it ok this effect this is
annoying
thank you ah
you have a great life sir you have a
great life you beautiful I would become
a model if I were you I know what you
fear I will rain excrement into your
very soul I will destroy you you are too
[Music]
what are they doing
I [ __ ] you they're made out of children
so they still play and [ __ ]
that's the cutest thing I have ever
[ __ ] seen
oh no he flip it over again these like
it's stupid and fat keeps the way as
kids are just the cutest I look carpets
nice this place is awesome
look at those carpets Hey I mean tapers
whoa don't want to jump down there you
know what I'm saying la la la la la oh
this is fun I hope you're having fun
it's been a long journey today I hope
you're okay
you watch this indifferent stare at
times one setting manic I am one setting
at the foot of those stairs uh-huh
towards the red light of the nursery
sunset in the window
like a bleeding sky the horizon a slit
throat the seeping dark to drain that
give it promise I am the jugular faced
man
I am the feathered serpent this
priesthood is
I can all applaud your great engineer
how marvelous I must say mr. Mendez my
excitement is almost and secret yes I
can see that step this way I will be
right back
Landis find us with the dead without you
I can't see it well that's cool
be a pig they said it will be fun they
said that is a lot of [ __ ] blood man
please can I shower in it again oh it's
you guys
hi are you tearing out your hearts again
yeah I've seen that I'm very impressed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what ok surfing on the pig blood call I
climb instill this now blue water runs
in my veins now I carry the night of
this factory the bowl of this name I am
come to collect you from your feelings
and your furnaces I will gather you into
the white clouds I will gather you to me
and I will take you home
whoa whoa whoa that's awesome
I wanted to swim oh I can't it's it's
like yeah blood just thickened quickly
so it doesn't make sense I guess that is
some nice titties oh it's an ass [ __ ] I
hate when I mistake titties for ass
that's pretty hot well don't mind if I
do thank you very much
let's bring quite a journey hell every
don't mind if I jerk you yeah whatever
ha so don't be down like that don't be
down it's gonna be okay
like we're going down isn't that great
yeah whatever type here Jase you need to
change your attitude sir Jase I can't
work with this I'm sorry I just can't
we're going to kill that other guy now
is that what we're doing oh we're going
down there No
oh those are they do something okay
sorry
mandus many gears are just my steam is
built
my soul
can you believe all the [ __ ] this guy's
fields and I know help here
what the hell I know alright so this
will be the last time I see you I'll let
you there you go you're welcome
hey cool let's go in here this would be
great vacuum ever let's kill a clan
should I just yes
does your vacuum have a proper suction
go on tell me in the comments I'm
waiting
actually if you made it this far in this
video let me know because I'm curious
how many people actually watch this far
say potato salad take on grease nipples
and then something else every game you
don't know how to spell grease don't
worry just write whatever
our pig is about to come huh Oh
electrified pig's school
it's electrifying you better shape up
cuz I need a man who can Electrify my
Pig you better shape up cuz Electrify
pig ears my heart is telling pigs hey
baby baby pigs oh it's my children again
nice
I should never gets old this way I guess
it is pretty amazing that the design of
the levels it's very cool to walk
through all these areas and I think it
will make a lot of what's that [ __ ]
noise I think it will make a lot of cool
like custom stories with all this to
wear to quit don't you think I think
that's what I'd really look forward to
oh this is pretty cool area
whoa they can teleport let the [ __ ] hi
sorry Wow don't hit me bro
super kegs think they can be electrified
several Pink's think they're thunder or
lightning whatever is that it did I do
it cuz I saved the earth I think we did
it breasts
let's turn this [ __ ] off then
nope we can't koala great that was what
I was actually hoping for good I don't
even [ __ ] know what I'm doing
yeah oh sorry yes of course okay this is
creepy I like this I don't know where
we're going
come on game
Oh what was that all about feel like I
talk way too much in you breasted a if
anyone watched me from a weird
perspective they'd be like what the [ __ ]
is that guy doing
whoa need to save you oh we to spare you
I would have given my soul to spare you
this world and it slow
yeah well you didn't my children like
that
to hybrid car
I guess I sorry follows in the same
pattern as Anisha in the sense of the
character becoming something someone
that he doesn't want to be and he wants
to forget and then we uncovered the
truth from him being someone he didn't
want to be or whatever
that's cute we'll put it right to my
darlings at the right like the writing
to like the dialogues I know I didn't
read the text I don't know people have a
problem with it but it's [ __ ] boring
most of the time
all right Teddy this is said nice
breakdancing and up here darlings into
pie I'm sorry I'm sorry
sure sure mad sure whatever you say
that's the lamest excuse I ever heard
mandus put aside your misguided crusade
and let me save them you may hate me
madness but I have seen the future your
20th century and you talking about world
war the one what did I just get piggy
ported yeah do you part
get it get it
piggy what are you doing here ya
supposed to be here
[Music]
[ __ ] hey hey no sorry what the [ __ ]
that's kind of cool
I like that alright [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] stop teleporting you little
[ __ ]
alright sayonara
he can't teleport in me hi Kenny stop
pave a [ __ ] pig oh well I want to be
here
never mind hey thanks all right this is
it it's been a good journey brows I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna fork it's not
a heart it is a heart the machine has a
heart and it's dripping blood too well
there's this is awkward I'll be on my
way now
thank you nothing sorry about that
that's just awkward as how they I mean
to impose on your privacy just don't
wanna [ __ ] with hearts so anything I
heard about things in school actually I
never heard anything about anything
about anyone there's a ladder here I
think I'll take it thank you thank you
I'll be on my way you keep pumping get
it pump biggie I try you know what I try
I tried so hard
Oh what are you
and Spence expands yeah you spent two
sir
yes of course would you like to spend oh
well you're not going to would you like
to spend well your lucky day is today
wonderful oh this is fun I'm having a
great time
well now that there are spinning have
you now creature that will destroy you
madness
that's us right now hold on line all
that line
madness death as big
[Music]
it's the beginning of the game isn't it
no I don't have any friends I'm socially
awkward okay we saw the sing to save
humanity
ridding them of their painful stupid
pointless lives stupid pointless life
mandus stop think about what you're
doing for your children
oh we're going down their treadmill
thank
the temple steps know about the currency
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so somehow they foresaw the future of
like world war and such and they wanted
to make the machine to prevent it is
that it
[Music]
that's a pretty cool story it's a pretty
cool concept I'm not gonna argue with
that I just wish the game was [ __ ]
scary that's that's all I wanted out of
this game but instead they give you an
epic experience yeah it's definitely
definitely burned into the brickwork my
house of skulls in the junk oh I like
this
[Music]
enslave this is your coming century
[Music]
that's really cool I like that
[Music]
come on I wanted to see a for your
children the birth giving machine buy of
course
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't have any legs anyway
[Applause]
hey we can be friends right
we're cool we cool I think we're cool ah
geez
[Music]
alright that was a Mesa ma machine for
pigs I quite liked it in the end
honestly I didn't think I would like it
I know a lot of people had a problem
with this story in the ending I thought
it was kind of cool
ah this game I don't know I really don't
know I like that and what's the god I
had created it down at the end when we
were cold as the stone we had huge his
body from when the lights were nearly
all extinguish we heard in the silent
distance the man singing tomorrow then
as the last lights were gone and we laid
together in deep
they drifted away inside such a silence
I have never
[Music]
and as the dust settled on my open I and
we lay together embraced forever
I heard miles above us the sounds of the
city turning over in its sleep
the church bell when he had and in that
moment
the new century was born
so really reverted everything with the
machine I guess I mean the pigs aren't
killing
[Music]
mandus company huh what a great [ __ ]
place
[Laughter]
okay now it's over I'm sorry I've
started a little earlier um no sound for
the credits
well [ __ ] alright I think it wasn't
it was better than I thought in the end
but at the same time
III know already that a lot of people
are disappointed with this game because
it's just not scary I mean obviously a
mission the reason why everyone might be
shy is so popular it's because it's
scared let's let's be honest
obviously to seek out and and try to
beat amnesia and being scary that's it's
not an easy thing to do that's not gonna
happen mostly close of the case
especially since most of us have played
amnesia we're not gonna be as scared as
planning in other words so maybe I like
this music better so maybe they did the
right approach after all then just be
like [ __ ] it we're not gonna make it
scary we'll just deliver an epic story
inside
I just wish I got into the story earlier
instead of instead of escaping that was
right away because that is made me not
interested there were a lot of
improvements from from the first game of
how I were like with the design of the
scenery and everything like that it's
pretty [ __ ] epic and I think that
that makes me excited for custom stories
in this game for someone to make it
really actually scary in the music and
the dialogue it's all improved upon in
my opinion anything and I really liked
the idea of the story as well but I know
I know the ones who made amnesia the
Dark Descent they sought out to make the
scariest game map you know for sure this
is not where they had in mind when they
made this gaming I wish them dis made
this game instead of by themself instead
of calling it amnesia because I feel
like they didn't really have to make
this animation today and so I think a
lot of people will you know fans will be
disappointed because it's not what they
expect them and I know they marketed
this game come to be and really really
scary as well so I mean they kind of
[ __ ] himself in the end there
[Music]
but otherwise it's a cool game I I kind
of learned me not to you know I know a
lot of people pre-order it for example I
feel and then when i pre-ordered it if I
knew afterwards that it was going to be
something completely different than I
expected
I think that's why I learned from this
on pre-order games I guess I still don't
forget buying it I still think it's a
cool game it's an excellent game to be
fully on is this is not the game that we
expected so that's that
either way looking forward to custom
stories coming out of this I think
that'll be fun to play
thank you bros for watching this [ __ ]
two hours or probably one-and-a-half
hours here and video that's pretty
awesome of you and maybe you just skip
to the end or whatever that's cool I
don't care I wanted to finish the game I
felt like I had to kind of but so I'm
glad I did because it was pretty cool so
thanks for watching bros they be like
I've been doing watching hit subscribe a
couple of red today I'll see you in the
next video
stay awesome bros love you
[Music]
whoa you idiot vodka top man get off me
ugly [ __ ] [ __ ]